so depending on which side of the internet you sit on
you were gonna see one or the other
parents hating on child free people or child free people hating on parents
and in my opinion
anybody who has to be that negative
or dismissive or insulting to people who make different choices
have their own shit to unpack
but devil's advocate
people who choose to be child free
so not people who end up there by circumstance
people who make that choice are going against the cultural norm
and whenever you make any choice that goes against the cultural norm
you are gonna get backlash
and a lot more backlash than you're ever gonna get in person
for making the traditional choice
over time that can make somebody bitter and angry
it doesn't excuse being an asshole
but as we know
people on the internet love being a little bit brave
and a little bit extra assholely
over here I'm gonna go ahead and make another video
talking about this whole selfish argument
because everyone who either has kids or doesn't have kids
is called selfish for their choice by the angry on the opposite side
and I think it's time that we kind of all collectively dissect that
so we can move forward with this conversation
so that'll be the next video I post
right after this one